c'est pourquoi nous vous demandons
monsieur le premier ministre d'entendre
cette vérité première
nous ne faisons pas semblant d'aller mal
pour obtenir
dernière université d'été pour laurence
parisot présidente du medef comme chaque
année le campus de hec si tu as joué en
josas a accueilli le grand rassemblement
des chefs d'entreprise pendant trois
jours avant la rentrée mercredi 29 août
le premier ministre jean-marc ayrault
s'est rendu sur place pour le lancement
je m'étonne de cet étonnement
à propos de ma présence parmi vous et
pendant 35 ans j'ai rencontré des chefs
d'entreprises dont venir à l'université
d'été c'est une première mais rencontrer
les chefs d'entreprise pour moi c'est
une habitude parce que c'est une
évidence on construit pas l'avenir du
pays sans se parler est d'abord parler
avec les chefs d'entreprise comme je
parle aussi avec les salariés comme je
parle avec tous les français donc pour
moi c'est évident je répondu à votre
invitation
c'est une grande première si nicolas
sarkozy ancien président de la
république avait participé à la
rencontre du medef en 2007 jamais un
premier ministre en fonction n'avait
fait le déplacement vous étions quittés
avant l'été sur une mésentente lors de
la grande conférence sociale
le travail avait bien sûr repris depuis
mai nous semblait absolument
indispensable qu'il y ait un signe du
gouvernement à l'égard des entreprises
pourquoi parce que celle ci traverse une
période extraordinairement difficile et
ceci nous concerne tous pas simplement
nous chefs d'entreprise pas simplement
nous cadres dirigeants mais tous les
français car la croissance
passe par les résultats des entreprises
l'intervention de jean marc ayrault a
été appuyé par une forte présence des
membres du gouvernement comme michel
sapin ministre du travail pierre
moscovici ministre de l'économie et des
finances ou encore arnaud montebourg
ministre du redressement productif
aucune annonce concrète de la part du
premier ministre mais un appel à la
négociation sur la sécurisation de
l'emploi à quelques jours de la
publication des chiffres du chômage en
forte hausse jean marc ayrault est
revenu sur le projet des quatre cent
mille contrats aidés sans oublier les
emplois d'avenir quant aux emplois
d'avenir dont le projet était adopté ce
matin par le conseil des ministres il
contribue aussi à apporter une réponse à
la fois rapide et ambitieuse à cette
question
ambitieuse car nous voulons créer cent
cinquante mille emplois d'avenir dès la
première année et avec ces emplois nous
visons d'abord les jeunes les plus
éloignés de l'emploi ceux qui sont sans
diplôme ou qui sont peu qualifiés en
priorité dans les quartiers les plus
populaires ou dans les zones rurales en
difficulté une proposition loin de
satisfaire la présidente du medef qui
regrette la fin du dispositif zéro
charges pour toute embauche nouvelle
dans une tpe et ce serait certainement
beaucoup plus vertueux pour tout le
monde de créer d'assiter les emplois
dans le secteur privé plutôt que dans le
secteur public ou associatif notamment
du côté du serveur public il faut faire
très attention on a quand même un enjeu
d'équilibré des finances publiques qui
est un sacré défi